[Musique]
ça n'a vraiment aucun sens on commence
par quoi par le début je suis entré dans
l'ascenseur avec ses deux tours du puits
qui m'est montée avec nous
dans approximativement 12 minutes je
vais me faire assassiner
selon la police tim connolly a été
victime d'un meurtre et apparemment
c'est l'oeuvre d'un givre et dans votre
genre
je peux pas m'empêcher de penser moi non
plus on devrait faire notre propre
podcast alors on va y descendre et on va
chercher des indices pour voulait venir
est ce que je veux me produire dans
l'appartement d'un mort et fouiller dans
ses affaires j'ai rien de mieux à faire
[Musique]
la seule chose qui compte si nous avons
raison c'est qu'il ya un tueur en
liberté dans notre immeuble vous êtes
une très bonne réplique mal interprété
mais excellente je crois qu'on a mis le
doigt sur quelque chose et c'est quoi ça
des photos de nos voisins prises sur le
vif pourquoi ce sont toutes des selles
fille pour que je ne sois pas soupçonner
qu est-ce que ces journées forcé de
faire ça dans un placard l'acoustique et
bien meilleures ici et croyez-moi il
vous faut ne jamais tomber dans les
pommes c'est lucky le comment le
pourquoi et le pourquoi pas et vous avez
le quoi et le quoi pourquoi vous dites
le quoi j'ai jamais dit quoi y'a pas de
quoi
là c'est carrément la merde je crois que
notre liste de suspects vient encore de
s'allonger
[Musique]
tenez bon
sortez du bâtiment immédiatement poids
l'exclusion et d'exclamations
garder l'oeil ouvert tout peut être un
indice
[Musique]
il y a de grandes chances pour que
l'assassin soit la légende de la musique
sting
les gars de youtube aux
et vous cet accord pour que je vous
enregistre dit n'importe quoi pour qu'on
s'en tienne s'il vous plaît merci
parfait je crois pas que je veux pas que
vous enregistrez on arrête
j'adore l'émotion ne changeait rien mais
j'ai besoin que vous articule y ait un
peu plus vous êtes d'accord oui vos
pleurs recouvre le thé alors oui c'est
vrai il a raison ok alors que quand vous
voulez et actions